روما يمكنك القول إنها ذاهبة إلى
الخنازير البرية التي يقوم
عمال المدينة ببذل كل ما في
وسعهم لمنعهم من إغراق
العاصمة الإيطالية
ولكن مع القليل من النجاح ، فإن
الخنازير البرية ليست مجرد مصدر إزعاج
للسكان الذين يقلقون المسؤولين ،
فهناك أيضًا خطر  إنهم يحملون
أنفلونزا الخنازير التي لا تشكل خطورة على
البشر ولكنها يمكن أن تؤثر على الإمدادات الغذائية
مع مشكلة الخنازير البرية
لدينا مشكلة خطيرة للغاية
بسببهم أن أنفلونزا الخنازير الأفريقية موجودة الآن في
أراضينا وهذا جزء خطير للغاية
من مشكلة  بالطبع هو أن
هناك الكثير من الطعام عندما تأتي الحرب البرية
إلى المدينة ،
وهناك عدد قليل من الخيارات على الطاولة
للتخلص من الآفات ،
فماذا تعتقد أن المدينة يجب أن تفعله
لوقف المشكلة
تقتلهم ،
إنها الموجة المقدسة
في المدينة  من روما يعمل على خطة
للقيام بذلك فقط من خلال جلب مجموعة من
الصيادين لإعدام القطيع الذي يقدر
بحوالي 20000 في روما وحولها الذين
يأتون إلى المدينة للبحث عن الطعام الذي
يقوم به الرومان.  لا تنزه في
المناطق التي يرعى فيها الخنازير ، ويطلب
منهم أيضًا تطهير الأحذية
والأيدي قبل مغادرة الحدائق
ولكن لا يتفق الجميع مع الحاجة إلى
قتل هذه الوحوش ،
فأنا لا أحب هذا الحل ، فأنا لا
أريد
أن
قتل  الموقد الأبيض لأنني لا أعتقد
أنهم خطرون
ولكن هناك القليل من الخيارات لأن الإنسان
والوحش لا يمكن أن يتعايشا على الأقل ليس من السهل
باربي الكثير من nadeau cnn
لك